why can't dl as a postdoctoral training
and I was particularly interested in
endocrinology in general but diabetes
and actually had a chance to work with
dr. Robert Sherwin we started on this
project in the late 70s when at a time
when insulin delivery was very hard to
achieve in a physiologic way patients
had about a 15 to 20 year reduction in
life expectancy and diabetes was the
leading cause of kidney disease
blindness amputations the pump story is
a little complicated i was actually
looking for a way to deliver a hormone
not insulin to people with diabetes over
a few days and actually there were
children in the Children's Clinical
Research Center at Yale who are using a
portable infusion pump to give a
different medication for a blood
disorder when he showed it to me it
really turned out that had all the
features you needed for delivering it
delivering insulin I looked at the pump
and I thought this was a device that
could give a medication around the clock
which it could at a steady rate but what
I didn't know was that there was a
little red button on the pump that said
instant dose button and that's the kind
of little extra feature that would be
perfect for diabetes because the
pancreas makes some insulin all the time
a little bit that trickles in which
could be the continuous infusion but
when you eat you need an extra blast of
insulin and that's where the instant
dose button could come in by just
turning knobs up pressing a button the
patients could get a dose for every time
they ate the idea of a pump which could
be deliver insulin in small amounts
continuously and augment delivery when
you aid was a new concept
at the time and really changed I think
the way we manage diabetes in the future
both via the pump as well as clinically
with injections the difference between
having diabetes now compared to her was
years ago before pump treatment is like
maybe the difference between day and
night okay even with a relatively small
number of advances we're doing so much
better it's almost really hard to
imagine